C'est devenu une partie de ma vie, donc c'est la fin
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais envie d'aller jusqu'au bout
Je ne veux jamais mourir jusque-là
pensée
Mais que se passe-t-il quand c'est fini
L'endroit où je sens que je vais être triste
je pense qu'il y a
[musique]
Ensoleillé
Montez et faites un gâteau avec le motif de la mer
Je l'ai eu, mais quand je l'ai donné
La réaction de tout le monde était comme
et ça m'a fait plaisir
[musique]
dire
Je suis un maniaque de One Piece, mais pas tellement
J'ai essayé de ne pas collectionner les figurines.
Même si ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
Eh bien, c'est le meilleur parmi diverses choses
J'aime
Il y a environ trois ans, dans ce centre de jeu
obtenir ceci
Supervisé par One Piece Mania
Il y a une figurine et la finition est un peu étonnante
Bien
[musique]